hey guys well I'm so excited because
tonight I'm going to the Grammy Awards
I'm gonna be on the red carpet so I need
to be red carpet ready now as you ladies
know it's quite a process to actually
get ready but guys just think it's this
magical thing that just happens let me
tell you it's not so take you guys
through the entire thing I have a French
ofte here she's my amazing makeup artist
I've worked with her for the past couple
years we have Diana who's gonna be
styling and I have one last secret
weapon you guys ask me all the time
Justine you drink so much coffee how do
you keep that smile so dazzling well
tell you just let me finish the scope of
goth papers red carpets are always so
much fun but it's kind of stressful
because you're walking there's people
taking pictures and there's videos but
the one thing that I always feel great
about is if you just smile you look like
you know what you're doing
so do I look like I know what I'm doing
right Justin something done Crest
Whitestrips I've been using these for as
long as I can remember and the amount of
coffee that I drink you would never even
know they're so easy to use all you do
is open up the package
peel off the upper and lower strips if
you're not sure which one the upper one
is it's the longer one the short one is
the bottom and apply to teeth these are
the 30-minute ones which means I can
play like two and a half rounds of Call
of Duty multiplayer flips out perfect
[Music]
when your time's up take them off and
reveal your smell and you're ready to go
I am now red carpet-ready
except for the rest of me Francesca I
think we should do a very pretty sultry
sexy eye something that's still bright
and fresh looking real fresh super fresh
we're gonna go super fresh how French
real fresh all right so let's start out
with the ice first so we're using the
creme shadows and this one's called
platinum Club where are we going the
club to the club or the red carpet
that's gonna catch the light on my
Garvey this is something called tight
lining to go right into the roots of the
eyelash see how much definition she has
do you see it
[Music]
get that cover that up
Justine never breaks out and of course
she got is it for for the Grammys is
this for like listen I'm coming out I
want to hang out of the very me she'll
just be a little concealer and concealer
and a smile have to be that way to get
again yeah no kidding
alright what's next I'm feeling so
fabulous
[Music]
Karen makeup is complete now we're gonna
head upstairs and put on the dress I
[Music]
think this is my favorite I absolutely
love it
[Music]
thank you so much for watching I'm about
to head off to the Grammys now I'll be
reading all of your tweets so be sure to
use the hashtag smile style and bonus
points if you actually show me your
smile style
so show me some teeth tweet it Instagram
it use the hashtag and in my free time
at the Grammys I'll be tweeting so see
you guys there
bye
[Music]